we should win something you guys I feel
like we died yeah I feel like we need to
go shopping at Van Cleef after this hi
I'm Sean Hayes and I'm Debra Messing and
we are playing the BuzzFeed BFF he
imitated Debbie Reynolds in a scene and
I farted loud I said it out loud
oh you did I just read to the audience
she was so proud of that
[Music]
Oh oh that was a good answer which is
true both people I think I think I wrote
what she wrote just more efficiently
well no it could be totally different
repair if we're and I said hold hands in
a circle and say a mantra three times
right half which is what Deborah started
from the pilot I'm the pilot for eight
years
yeah every single show and it's good
because it bonds us
[Music]
all right ready it's it's this just most
brilliant scene where he comes in
holding a cup a cup of coffee and he
does not stop talking he comes in and
he's like and what closes the door yes
and they were so kind because they knew
how can I swear they knew how [ __ ]
hard I was concentrating because I
didn't stop talking for like three pages
so all they saw my face must be just
saying word and but I liked it because
it was a big challenge
Oh juggling knitting and seeing you know
used to always hang I went through a
crazy knitting phase on set and it's
very clean it should come in and be like
look I made this outfit look I made this
kind of like what that tastes like feet
that takes a company like two years to
make and but it's very kind of you to
say that it's a hidden talent yes and
standing is rocky
[Music]
I've still Matthew because Matt and I
used to play softball here yes and we
loved all of them oh I can't believe but
the only thing is is Matt and I used to
play softball right like I'm the little
team in Santa Monica and and I just
asked when I'm like hey t wanted this
show he's like okay and it was it and so
we did the show I wanted to be you're
gonna say that because he was more your
storyline than well I guess so yeah he
was thought but he dated you that roots
I know I know I should have been I'm
gonna preface this by saying I am
colorblind
[Laughter]
either green or brown what are they
they're hazel green green yeah yeah
I literally honestly cannot tell green
but I Brad I've got orange around the
center oh she's a pumpkin shut up guys
I knew that Shawn was my brother yeah
absolutely but through this game I
learned that he really is like this
I learned that because she just said
that I would probably sleep with her I
also learned that that's totally not
true and but I also I would say I learn
nothing because I already know
everything about it
but didn't you sleep with me but not
really right it always the same
[Music]